we know a little more this morning about
a missing University of Utah
student and where she was before she
disappeared more than a week ago police
say Mackenzie looook was last seen
eating an unknown person in the middle
of the night CTM lead national
correspondent David vague know is
following this story David what more we
learning we have received a host of new
information since we first brought you
this story 24 hours ago police say
Mackenzie Luwak arrived at Salt Lake
City International Airport early last
week she took a lift to hatch Park which
is about 20 minutes from the airport
right off the 15th freeway when she got
there investigators say the 23 year old
met an unknown individual put her bag in
that person's car seemed happy to see
the person and then left she hasn't been
seen or heard from since our detectives
have been working around the clock in
this case police in Salt Lake City
worked overnight to find the person who
met makenzie Luwak at that park the
morning she disappeared Salt Lake's
Assistant Police Chief Tim doubt says
investigators have been searching the
area for clues looking for surveillance
footage
detectives are spoken with the lift
driver and learned that Mackenzie was
met at hatch Park by an individual in a
vehicle the lift driver left makenzie at
the park with that person and stated
that makenzie did not appear to be in
any type of distress investigators have
given us this timeline which starts at
about 135 a.m. on Monday June 17th when
looook landed at Salt Lake City
International Airport after going home
to California for her grandmother's
funeral she texted her mother at 2:01
a.m. to let her know she had arrived
about 40 minutes later looook took a
lift from the airport to hatch Park
which is in North Salt Lake City she
arrived there just before 3 a.m.
detectives have interviewed her friends
and acquaintances from school and we
have checked locations she was known to
frequent doubt says looook cell phone
isn't ringing no call no email no social
media nothing
a spokesperson for loic's family tells
CBS News that a major part of the police
investigation is Loic stating life and
her use of dating apps investigators are
exploring whether she had any secret
social media accounts or an alternative
we don't have any evidence that any foul
play has occurred but the circumstances
of her just going off the grid it's
concerning to us our CBS affiliate in
Salt Lake City reports that police have
six officers who are working a tip line
this morning we've actually posted the
number on our website I'll give it to
you now it's 801 seven nine nine forty
420 keep in mind she missed her midterm
college exam and she was supposed to fly
home to Los Angeles on Sunday but she
didn't make that flight either peculiar
circumstances in the three am ann
reardon of a park and getting into
another car who takes a lift to get to a
car it's just look bottom line she's an
adult if she's okay and she wants to go
off the grid that's cool but they want
to hear from her you hear David it is
very disturbing to many milestones that
she missed yes is apparently responsible
and reliable yes she hasn't been heard
from not a word all right we'll stay on
top of that story thank you